aristotle was born around 384 bc
in the ancient greek kingdom of
macedonia where his father was the royal
doctor
he grew up to be arguably the most
influential philosopher ever
with modest nicknames like the master
and simply the philosopher
his first big job was tutoring alexander
the great who soon after went out and
conquered the known world
aristotle then headed off to athens
worked with plato for a bit then
branched out on his own
he founded a little school called the
lyceum french secondary schools that
lise
are named in honor of this venture he
liked to walk about while teaching and
discussing ideas
his followers were nicknamed
peripatetics the wanderers his many
books are actually lecture notes
aristotle was fascinated by how many
things actually work
how does a chick grow in an egg how does
squid reproduce
why does a plant grow well in one place
and hardly at all in another
and most importantly what makes a human
life and a whole society go well
for aristotle philosophy was about
practical wisdom
here are four big philosophical
questions he answered
one what makes people happy in the
nicomachean ethics
the book got its name because it was
edited by his son nicomachus
aristotle set himself the task of
identifying the factors
that lead people to have a good life or
not
he suggested that good and successful
people all possess distinct virtues
and propose that we should get better at
identifying what these are
so that we can nurture them in ourselves
and honour them in others
aristotle zeroed in on eleven virtues
courage temperance liberality
magnificence magnanimity pride patience
truthfulness wittiness friendliness
modesty
aristotle also observed that every
virtue seems to be bang in the middle of
two vices
it occupies what he termed the golden
mean between two extremes of character
for example in book four of his ethics
under the charming title of
conversational virtues wit buffoonery
and boorishness
aristotle looks at ways people are
better or worse at conversation
knowing how to have a good conversation
is one of the key ingredients of the
good life
aristotle recognized some people go
wrong
because they lack a subtle sense of
humor that's the boar
someone useless for any kind of social
intercourse because he contributes
nothing
and takes offense at everything but
others carry humor to excess
the buffoon cannot resist a joke sparing
neither himself nor anybody else
provided that he can raise a laugh and
saying things that a man of taste would
never dream of saying
so the virtuous person is in the golden
mean in this area
witty but tactful a particularly
fascinating moment is when aristotle
draws up a table of
too little too much and just right
around the whole host of virtues
we can't change our behavior in any of
these areas just at the drop of a hat
but change is possible eventually moral
goodness says aristotle is the result of
habit
it takes time practice encouragement so
aristotle thinks
people who lack virtue should be
understood as unfortunate rather than
wicked what they need isn't scolding or
being thrown into prison
but better teachers and more guidance
two what's art for the blockbuster art
at the time
was tragedy athenians watched gory plays
at community festivals in huge open air
theaters
esculus euripides and sophocles were
household names
aristotle wrote how to write great
play's manual the poetics
it's packed with great tips for example
make sure to use peripatea
a change in fortune when for the hero
things go from great to awful
in titanic leonardo dicaprio gets kate
winslet great then they hit the iceberg
awful and anagnorisis a moment of
dramatic revelation when suddenly the
hero works out their life is a
catastrophe
but what is tragedy actually for what's
the point of a whole community coming
together to watch horrible things
happening to lead characters
like oedipus in the play by sophocles
who by accident kills his father gets
married to his mother
finds out he's done these things and
gouges out his own eyes in remorse and
despair
aristotle's answer is catharsis which is
greek for
catharsis catharsis is a kind of
cleaning you get rid of bad stuff
in this case cleaning up our emotions
specifically our confusions around the
feelings of fear and pity
we've got natural problems here we're
hard hearted we don't give pity where
it's deserved
and we're prone to either exaggerated
fears or not getting frightened enough
tragedy reminds us that terrible things
can befall decent people
including ourselves a small flaw can
lead to a whole life unravelling
and so we should have more compassion or
pity for those whose actions go
disastrously wrong
we need to be collectively re-taught
these crucial truths on a regular basis
the task of art as aristotle saw it is
to make profound truths about life
stick in our minds three
what are friends for in books eight and
nine of the nicomachean ethics
aristotle identifies three different
kinds of friendship
there's friendship that comes about when
each person is seeking fun
their chief interest is in their own
pleasure and the opportunity of the
moment
which the other person provides then
there are friendships that are really
strategic acquaintances they take
pleasure in each other's company
only in so far as they have hopes of
advantage of it
then there's the true friend not someone
who's just like you
but someone who isn't you but about whom
you care as much as you care about
yourself
the sorrows of a true friend are your
sorrows their joys are yours
it makes you more vulnerable should
anything befall this person but it's
hugely strengthening too
you're relieved from the too small orbit
of your own thoughts and worries
you expand into the life of another
together you become larger cleverer more
resilient more fair-minded
you share virtues and cancel out each
other's defects
friendship teaches us what we ought to
be it's quite literally
the best part of life four how can ideas
cut through in a busy world
like a lot of people aristotle was
struck by the fact that the best
argument doesn't always win the debate
or the battle
he wanted to know why this happens and
what we can do about it
he had lots of opportunity for
observations in athens
lots of decisions were made in public
meetings often in the agora the town
square
orators would vie with one another to
sway popular opinion
aristotle plotted the ways audiences and
individuals are influenced by many
factors
that don't strictly engage with logic or
the facts of the case
it's maddening and many serious people
especially plato can't stand it
they avoid the marketplace and populist
debate aristotle was more ambitious
he invented the art of what we still
today call rhetoric
the art of getting people to agree with
you he wanted thoughtful
serious and well-intentioned people to
learn how to be persuasive
to reach those who don't agree already
he makes some timeless points
you have to recognize acknowledge and
soothe people's fears you have to see
the emotional side of the issue
is someone's pride on the line are they
feeling embarrassed and edge around it
accordingly
you have to make it funny because
attention spans are short
and you might have to use illustrations
and examples to make your point come
alive
we're keen students of aristotle today
philosophy doesn't sound like the most
practical activity
maybe that's because we've not paid
enough attention recently
to aristotle
you